hs2 promised to deliver so much and what
we're doing is leveling up across the
country
but it's been played with setbacks
ballooning budgets and now parts of it
have had to be cancelled altogether
it's a second class option championship
option when we needed a premier league
option because you cannot level up the
north of england on second best
[Music]
first mooted by labor in 2009 hs2 is a
massive high-speed rail project that
links london and major cities in the
north we're building in two phases
[Music]
phase one is a new line between london
houston and the west midlands originally
slated to open in 2026 phase one is now
expected to open between 2029 and 2033.
phase two was split into two parts 2a
connected birmingham to crew while 2b
continued on west to manchester and east
to the east midlands and leeds
with these changes the journey from
london to crew will reduce from 90
minutes to 56 minutes
[Music]
but in its latest setback the hs2
expansion has been watered down another
rail line known as northern powerhouse
rail which would have connected leads to
manchester via bradford is not going
ahead and in the eastern lake from east
midlands to leeds will now be scrapped
[Music]
since hs2 was announced 500 million
pounds worth of investment has been
attracted to leeds
crossrail of the north i will shorten
journey time 55 minutes to manchester
manchester leeds for 33 minutes but what
we're also doing is a crossrail of the
midlands from the west midlands to the
eastmans from the first time in the
history of our country uh running from
uh birmingham uh to nottingham which
which currently takes one hour and
fourteen minutes gonna get it down to 26
minutes and we will look at what we can
do uh going forward to lead
but by 2050 40 000 extra jobs were
expected as well as a boost to the
economy of over 50 billion pounds it's
raised massive questions about the
government's promises to level up the
north and could pose problems for tories
in red wall seats
so i have to say madam deputy speaker
that i am deeply disappointed by today's
announcement the bradford district has
been in my view completely short changed
this is the danger in selling perpetual
sunlight
and then leaving it for others to
explain the arrival of moonlight
environmentalists and conservationists
have long been against hs2 because of
deforestation and destruction to the
ecosystem they will be in there as long
as it takes
and you know some people say why why are
you persisting in stopping this and
increasing the time scale but the amount
of money that is spent although it's a
massive amount of security on the other
side of the road it's just dropping the
ocean compared to the overall spend of
hs2
but with transport being the largest
contributor to carbon emissions in the
uk a greener solution is necessary
hs2 said that in 2030 it will offer some
of the lowest carbon emissions per
passenger per kilometer 17 times less
than air travel and seven times less
than car it would also be twice as
efficient as a conventional train
network
with a nearly a hundred billion pound
price tag that's more than triple its
original 30 billion the tories felt
something had to give unfortunately for
those in the north it appears to be rail